alors on va voir la réaction du général
de gaulle et des gouvernements à travers
jean politti dans quelques instants mais
j'aimerais vous montrer combien les
moeurs ont changé donc c'est en cela que
mai 68 a réussi en quelque sorte on va
le vérifier à travers deux témoignages
le premier de l'une des premières
féministes avant même le mlf et le
second d'un couple séduit en 68 comme
beaucoup de jeunes par cette fameuse vie
en communauté
depuis il porte un regard on va dire que
distancié sur tout cela reportage d'aude
jarre griesbeck avec jean-jacques le
garrec changer la vie le souhait de
rimbaud était mise en pratique dès
l'occupation de la sorbonne par les
étudiants pas un lieu sans débat pas de
sujet tabou le vertige du tout est
possible pendant qu'on était à la
sorbonne on s'apercevait qu'il n'y avait
rien sur les femmes alors on a commencé
à placarder des slogans ensuite on est
montés au premier étage où ont réservé
les salles et là on a dit ben il ya un
petit problème on parle pas des femmes
ah c'est vrai on parle pas des femmes
alors on va faire un meeting un débat
vous prenez la l'amphi des cartes pour
demain et vous nous organiser ça et le
lendemain à 20 heures on attendait
on pensait qu'ils auraient percé quand
on a vu peuple en 6e remplir se remplir
tellement qu'on refusait les gens on
était en bas c'est un amphi comme ça y
est j'ai ressenti une des plus belles
émotions de ma vie c'était enfin les
barrières briser la parole qui circulait
on se souriaient
bon c'est peut-être des moments comme ça
de grâce dans l'histoire mais celui là
il a vraiment existé ce moment de grâce
maryvonne et michal ont voulu le
prolonger en vivant en communauté
c'était après mai 68 en lozère c'est nos
premières plantations
parce qu'évidemment vous savez tout
juste comment pousser les haricots verts
on supposait
que à la campagne les gens la campagne
était plus près de la nature
donc qu'ils étaient plus près d'une
vérité et ça ça a été très fort jamais
dire pas très longtemps ce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que les possédés papiss la
vérité que nous il y avait cette espèce
d'insouciance comme on passait pas par
lord au boulot on s'en foutait d'avoir
du boulot ou pas c'est une le monde ne
nous appartenait si vous roulez pas les
gros bras si vous n'êtes pas macho que
vous qui collait pas que vous avez pas
une grosse voiture
des nanas où vous en faites pas et après
caillé 68 il ya une espèce de libération
l'avait le mouvement féministe qui
commençait les filles commencent et
apprend à prendre a décidé elle-même il
ya on pouvait on pouvait avec des filles
sans être comme ça le gros machos bête
et ça c'est là ça il ya eu aussi une
explosion on baignait dans une notion de
plaisir il y avait dans cette notion de
plaies de plaisir afin d'être en voulait
voilà c'est que ça on était mue par par
la recherche du plaisir on était dans le
il faut il fout des conventions sociales
à nos parents disait tout le temps il
faut pas faire social musée batha cause
voilà et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
explosion à ce niveau là en 68 et
c'était la démarche on va être bien
ensemble
c'était ça c'est pas envahir tous en
forme tous ensemble trente ans après on
regarde les photos avec nostalgie même
si la fête est finie même si la
révolution a échoué mai 68 a sans
conteste bouleversé les mentalités et
c'est sans doute le plus important